brought to you by PlayStation Store
access to the ultimate and games and
entertainment the latest in the
battlefield series battlefield hardline
bbp you cops vs robbers it's fine
players it's finally out today both
single-player and multiplayer component
and our boy in the battlefield mr. Ryan
schubert is here to tell us all about it
sir you've been playing a lot of mud
spare over the weekend I've played a ton
of multiplayer over the weekend at tell
me what you think about this video game
I think it's really fun I think they've
put out a just supremely entertaining
multiplayer game when you say
entertaining what does that mean is that
it sounded kind of sounds like a
backhanded compliment well upon the
watch but not to play it's it's not as
sort of seriously toned as the last two
it's maybe a little bit more
tongue-in-cheek the way bad company was
and it's I mean you can drive a couch
around you know I mean it's not that's
not too serious and the you know they
paint the world with you know a lot of
here a lot of call outs like you
wouldn't titanfall can hear the people
talking and at one point last night
after a few gunshots went off i heard a
cop say i am the law I just thought you
know ice cracked up it's like okay you
know the theme is actually fun it's
refreshing it feels less stiff than
battlefield for din the company has a
lot to answer for a lot to live up to
after the disaster that with battlefield
4 they certainly do and I'm not sure
that this is going to necessarily win a
lot of fans back yeah because does it
feel like a full game or is it to me it
doesn't like to me it feels like a mod
but like a really good mod you know like
back when we got desert come back in
1942 like where it was something that
felt like a lot of work went into it a
lot of energy went into it but it
doesn't feel like a completely unique
game and it like frostbite maybe it's
frostbite but it's just not well
designed for the kind of game play like
you know for this sort of Grand Theft
Auto high-speed racing the game isn't
design
for like the collision yeah and the
handling and a lot of just really wonky
things happen when you drive vehicles so
it's kind of fun in spite of some like
technical limitation yes and thematic
stuff right and that's why i said like
if you downloaded it as a mod you would
say oh this is just fun hmm and i like
this and it's it's refreshing and to be
completely fair like I'm more of the
camp that bad company 2 was the sort of
height of multiplayer and map design
yeah and I was not a very big fan of
conquest as a result I mean I've played
most of the games in the series but I
just never quite latched on to it which
is interesting because it's like the
primary modal right it is but in and in
this interation I think they nailed it
really like I sat down at one point and
played through the entire playlist of
maps in conquest and I enjoyed
absolutely every one of them Wow and on
top of that there's a lot of new game
modes that are not all great but they're
all varied enough and different enough
and fun enough that if you sit down to
play and get tired of one you can switch
to the other and still enjoy yourself
yeah whereas I felt like in battlefield
4 I could really like hit a wall playing
one game mode and realize that I didn't
really want to switch to another one
maybe the exception is that team
deathmatch in this game is kind of
broken yeah my so they've gone to a full
64 player team deathmatch which is just
chaos into itself and then the map sizes
are all pretty small which is
appropriate for a team deathmatch but
then all the spawns are around the edge
right and I figured out at one point
that you can basically spawn and just
run around the edge in circles and
you'll just catch people spawning as you
go and it's not that fun and it's kind
of a deep way of racking up kills but
you know there you are I guess are you
enjoying it more than battlefield 4
multiplayer when I first came out um yes
I think so I mean for when it first came
out I was I was a lot more excited about
it and thematically i prefer the like
Wars onra to the crime yeah but this
is probably more fun not maybe not all
the maps are best designed but it's it's
just it feels entertaining it feels good
let's talk about the thematic side of it
then is it interesting have it like
would you say 64 player like 30 cops vs
30 robbers just shooting the [ __ ] out of
each other in a steady it conceptually
it makes basically no sense and I think
that's the thing is that's part of the
having fun side of it yeah and driving a
cash yeah driving a couch but and
conceptually though it does actually
work within a few of the setups like
it's not all just completely random like
why would you do this you know the new
heist mode which is involves like
breaking a vault and getting the money
out there's a few maps that that is like
really purpose-built for and we haven't
had a good a good set of purpose-built
maps in a long time like battlefield 3
and 4 when 3 launch they made a big deal
about every game mode was on every s
which was old and big red flag that it
was it was kind of a bad idea yeah you
know there were just some maps were just
made no sense especially rush which has
more of a linear feel to it and like it
tells a story yeah and going in a circle
on the circular map doesn't tell a story
really and that's better here I wouldn't
say that you know they've gotten rid of
rush which is kind of disappointing and
rush was that storytelling multiplayer
mode and I don't think any of the new
ones quite hit that mark yeah outside of
counter-strike we really don't get a lot
of games that have hostages as such a
main focus either right right and yes
there's a hostage mode there's basically
two modes that are five versus five you
know a sort of single elimination
matches in this sort of kind of struck
vein that I guess yeah and I actually
used to like that the version of that
mode when it was in call of duty called
Search and Destroy yeah yeah and I just
thought it was a great break from the
way the rest of the game modes played it
was like totally different you know you
only had one life you know I used to
play at hardcore so you didn't have any
mini maps or anything and you really had
to communicate with your team and
they've sort of they kind of added that
to battlefield 4 but
kind of fell flat and now they've got
two modes they've got crosshair and
rescue rescue is the hostage mode it's a
little bit more the flow of that one
doesn't quite play as well as I'd hoped
it would but the crosshair mode where
one of the players is the VIP yes who
gets a golden gun and nothing else and
is being escorted now there's a clip of
a are yeah that mode is actually really
fun hmm it's like best of nine and so
does there need to be a battlefield five
this year or really soon or is this kind
of good and will the seat your desire
for a battlefield game but for right now
I think for some people it will for some
people this is maybe another an
opportunity to try a battlefield game
without getting into like a core
battlefield game I mean my thing is I
think they should hold off as long as
they can on battlefield five I think
they need to regroup reconsider what
they're doing the frostbite they've got
battlefront on the way and on top of
that they're still sinking a lot of
support in the battlefield 4 like the
you know if anybody's noticed premium is
still full price raised oh they're still
like milking that wow you know to put
that in perspective that's like what 18
months old yeah and you know by
comparison titanfall came out around
this time last year a man all the dlc is
free now really so you know if you look
at just like the business model they're
both EA so you can't really necessarily
blame EA but you know the community test
environment is still an active thing
they're still doing new map work with it
there's a community map project going on
they've been doing nighttime versions of
some maps so I think what they're doing
is they're supporting battlefield 4 to
keep that core audience entertainment
battlefield 4 and hardline is just
another nice diversion version yeah so
we talked about the multiplayer it seems
like it's pretty solid seems like it's a
return to form a step in the right
direction at the very least and what of
the single player I'm from the little
I've seen through and you guys did a
stream and we had the reviews going up
on gamespot today as well it seems like
you can either mow down everyone or
you've got this magic badge you can just
flash in front of people know I gotta
okay oh god that guy didn't flash my
magic badge at him and how much have you
played and what do you think of it it's
kind of looks a lot different to the
multiplayer so I've only played the
first two episodes and all units so
right so it's divided in two episodes
and the episodes are actually delivered
in an episodic fashion they have like a
next time on and previously on kind of
structure or seed roll yeah and I
actually like that a lot really I you
know I'm as I've gotten older for me to
find time to like really dig into a
single player game actually being able
to treat it as an episodic makes it kind
of easier to digest yeah it's actually
kind of how I played the last call of
duty game 2 and I think it's a good
structure and you know now that it's
that you know EA is doing it looks like
it's really come fully mainstream and
tell tales been doing it for plenty of
time the auth you almost wish that they
did this like that like I do really yeah
I mean to me especially because this is
sort of a slightly off brand battlefield
I think it would have been kind of cool
if they released the full multiplayer
with like two episodes of the single
player you know bring the price point
down a little bit to get other people
through the door and then as they
release the story we'd have more time to
decide whether we want to follow the
story or you know just stick to the
multiplayer so when you're playing the
game are you mostly shoot everybody or
you a flash badge get down the graph so
again i only got into the first to sort
of levels which are still kind of
tutorial and i have to admit that as we
were doing it on the live stream last
week i was a little bit sort of
disappointed at how slow it was alright
i just i just wasn't ready for battle
field to be giving me like a stealth
game yeah like I wasn't ready and the
reviews on yeah I mean it was just it's
sort of out of left field and you know
maybe that's because I'm not that
familiar with visceral yeah but like
yeah you just saw the clip on the screen
like you you know you toss shell casings
to distract guards and then you know run
up flash your badge and you know Miguel
pointed it out and
his review how like there he said a free
exactly said they're like vampires like
to the Holy Cross yeah thank you flash
the badge and they like immediately look
they're like side of these heavily armed
guys with like vests and guns are like
oh man guys got a badge you know better
okay okay you know and then if you
slightly botched that they go full
lethal right away and there's nothing
brave about it it's like the the
eventual like evolution of this whole
single-player multiplayer campaign being
different is that you get multiplayer in
a single pair pack campaign and it could
be completely different games it looks
like and honestly I kind of feel like
you know at some point we should
consider even like considering them
different games like reviewing them
separately yeah you know cuz I don't
think it's fair in them separately even
selling them separately I don't know if
it's fair to a game to like mark it down
for having a you know subpar one or the
other when you know you know that one
thing is primary for you as a player I
don't remember because it's been a while
but I feel like probably you know
something like Bioshock which tried to
tack on a bike to try to Jack on a
multiplayer and I imagine it got a
little bit penalized for it's like well
then what resources in time and money
went into something which people wanted
that single player experience so it's
like maybe feeling if you'd put that
money towards heightening that that
single player experience would it have
been better it's interesting though when
you consider it's so many single player
and multiplayer like components are
actually made by separate teams right
surely this one well and they real
different too yeah I mean that was the
other thing that was so jarring to me
playing a single player of this which
was that you know the controls are
slightly different there's different
equipment that isn't in the multiplayer
game and I know that's kind of common
but it feels really awkward to you you
know to the stark contrast between a
almost Splinter Cell like or metal gear
style experience and the just
wall-to-wall insanity that multi player
is there's not even a you know they're
not even similar yeah what is the chance
that at some point in multiplayer
they'll be badge mode where you just run
up get magic more like a new place
collateral damage mode and single player
where suddenly you're just like forget
mode and imagine in the current climate
visceral probably wanted to stay away
from that one yes just as far away as
possible yeah so do you think you're
going to be playing battlefields this is
the sound like the final question for
like battlefield fans is that like you
and iron and a bunch of folks in the
office I've been playing three forever
and then playing for forever do you
think you're going to be playing hard
line like six months from them that's a
tough question I mean I'm still kind of
shell-shocked from battlefield 4 yeah I
kind of have almost like a you know
Captain Kirk cannot forgive them for the
death of my son feeling like I just I
was so disappointed at that roll out how
it took so long to fix it I don't like
premium I think that there's something
basically wrong with that model I mean
at this point for hardline I think I've
played I played the beta on ps4 and xbox
one I played the early access on xbox
one I've played on ps4 for the full
release none of that progress carries
over yeah if you plan all of those
platforms premium doesn't carry over
between platforms and there are people
who play on multiple platforms
especially the really hardcore fans and
they're expected to shell out a hundred
and ten dollars per bat for the for the
experience and that might not even sting
so much if you didn't have to redo
everything yeah from the ground up i
mean i've started hardline multi player
four times now you know and it's like it
is knowing that the process of yeah who
would that be like if it you have your
one account like it's all tied in the
battle log if you login your PPC and
like here's my character i bought on the
pc game switch over to ps4 and here's my
character and i don't have to redo any
of that's what I'm saying even if I even
if I could reason paying 110 dollars per
platform at least give me the time yeah
the investment of my time of my life is
that it's not too much to ask a bottle
log perhaps
you